so I recently got this question  um from someone how do I get out of my  own way and become more of a leader in  my own life  well the great irony is you have to ask  for help this is one of the funny things  about being human which is we are both  individuals and members of groups of at  all times and so often we're just  preoccupied with how do I be a better  leader how do I find the perfect job how  do I find love me me well the irony is  to find those things we actually have to  help others do the same thing service so  find somebody else who's struggling just  find somebody else who's in their own  way find somebody who wants to be a  better leader and help them if you're  looking for love help somebody else find  love if you're looking for the perfect  job help somebody else find the perfect  job the great irony is we will learn  more and achieve more by helping others  solve the problems that we're struggling  with